[Laughter]
hi i'm erin and i
love pizza i love everything about pizza
you've got your crispy crust your sweet
tomato sauce and then some mozzarella on
top to bring everything together this is
not a friendship this is not a lust this
is a true love i've always kind of had a
secret ambition to
work in a pizza shop sometimes i'm like
maybe i'll just run away to italy find a
nice grandmother to live with and she
can teach me everything she knows about
pizza what i've always really wondered
is how can you toss a pizza it's a skill
i've always wanted to acquire so using
only the internet i have been challenged
to learn how to toss pizza dough in just
one day i'm scared
why am i so scared before i go to the
internet to learn how to toss pizza
dough i'm gonna try to do it with no
prior knowledge the one thing i do know
is that you need a lot of flour make
sure things aren't going to stick i
don't know how much flour i've seen
people do this kind of technique before
where you just push the dough down in
the middle and kind of go around this is
already starting out not as a circle so
things are going great maybe i'll do
some of this let gravity do the work one
two three
i think it might be time for me to do a
little research since you can learn
literally anything on the internet these
days i'm gonna watch a couple of videos
to see how to do this she's starting
with the finger thing that i was doing i
don't know what the name of that is but
she was also doing it that's interesting
i've never seen dough stretch on the
side of the table the classic way that
everyone wants to know how to learn is
the like tossing of the dough technique
that is what i want to learn you kind of
want to create a spinning motion with
your knuckles as you're throwing it in
the air doing it on your knuckles might
be a good way to do it because doing it
with my fingers i felt like i was poking
holes in the dough this guy literally
just dumped it in a whole thing of flour
so
maybe
that's the move oh my god he's so fast
how is he doing this they're just
throwing things around and then it's
great and it's a perfect circle
oh
oh my gosh i don't know if i'm gonna
make it to that in one day but we'll see
he did show me a good technique though
with using both of your hands so i'll
try that out too number one i think it's
really important to start out with a
good base and i really have to focus on
making sure that i set myself up for the
toss well i'm also gonna try instead of
using my fingers using my fists and
hopefully that will keep the dough from
becoming too thin
i've got my pizza dough here they did a
little bit of this back and forth from
what i remember they had it on two hands
and i'm gonna use my fist this time
instead of my fingers they twisted from
the dominant hand up into my left hand
maybe something
like this
oh that wasn't too bad
is this gonna translate to dough i'm not
really sure but i'm feeling good with
this towel
got too ambitious this is definitely
helping i'm glad i had this technique
for sure the towel really helps
[Music]
after using this towel i'm not feeling
too bad i think i can move on to the
real thing
i got myself an apron like a real chef
because whenever i see someone with an
apron i'm like that person they know how
to cook so i'm hoping those skills will
transfer to me through this apron all
right i'm gonna try instead of using my
fingers to use a fist
i'm so nervous
second time's the charm it's only up
from here that's the good part of this
right
[Music]
it's supposed to be a smiley face but
maybe this is how i'm really feeling
about this competition i'm having a hard
time because i'm not keeping it on my
knuckles it starts there and then by the
time it gets back down i forget
i saw them do this on the internet so
that must be what you do this helps a
lot actually
i caught it this is an improvement and
around
i feel like i've got the good basics
down and i want to try to work on the
height and maybe getting a little extra
spin in there so much power in my
i'm tired but i feel like almost there i
still have hope
[Music]
it's so much flower
[Music]
i caught it
oh
not bad i'm pretty close
that was really good
i need one more and even more
[Music]
let's go let's go that was so good look
it's fully intact
it looks beautiful this is the perfect
dough to make a nice pizza i think this
is as close i'm gonna get in day i'm
pretty proud of myself this really makes
me appreciate the people who do this
every single day and the work they put
into it and also it makes me appreciate
pizza a lot more which i didn't think
was possible i'm tired i'm hungry but
luckily i have enough dough to make
myself a pizza so that's what i'm gonna
go do right now am i re-a yet does this
make me reay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you